par le pouvoir investi en moi par le
conseil intergalactique, je prononce par la présente
un ordre de destruction sur la planète Terre
l'ail de test habituel un terrien
sera choisi au hasard Sapru végétalien utilise
le pouvoir absolu pour le bien mais s'il l'
utilise pour le mal la naissance de cochon sera éliminée
suppose qu'il y avait une chose que tu pourrais faire
qui changerait ta vie pour le mieux
oh c'est facile je pourrai voir
Catherine d'en bas je peux faire
bouger les choses vêtements habille-moi
tout ce que j'ai à faire est d'agiter ma main
Dennis être capable de  parle embrasse embrasse ce qui est
visqueux s'il te plaît s'il te plait s'il te plait rien d'
autre n'a d'importance viens y penser ça
ne me dérangerait pas de baiser ta jambe en ce
moment je pourrais résoudre tous les problèmes du
monde as tu pensé à cette chose à
travers des dogmes proches
de faire quoi que ce soit de bien,
laissez-moi avoir un très bon
corps et un très gros oh oh ce n'est pas
si gros évidemment j'étais égoïste je
ne pouvais pas rendre les gens heureux tous ceux qui sont
morts soient à nouveau en vie
n  o Je serais mort jamais tu es fou
peut-être président des États-Unis
voici les documents d'information pour la Syrie
le déficit d'Israël au Moyen-Orient
sibel Sibel fais juste semblant d'être à nouveau un
animal stupide je t'aime nouveau dîner tais-toi
shag one'll  donne moi le corps d'un
grand homme